charlie how are we doing so i am trying
to figure out how i can get
on the same emotional level of my
relationships as my husband is currently
uh oh does that mean you're gonna you're
gonna go up or gonna go down
up okay tell me about it
so our we've been married for about
eight and a half years
okay we had a really rough couple years
about three almost four years ago okay
some infidelity and we almost got
divorced and
things were just really terrible for
about a year and a half
when you say really rough time and some
infidelity you're speaking very vague so
did you cheat on him did he cheat on you
do you all both cheat on each other
what was that situation so my husband
had an affair okay for about six months
okay
and then he told me about it and then
for the following year
was kind of just this emotional
rollercoaster of us
trying to fix it and then him saying no
i want to be with this other girl
and okay let's try and fix it again no i
still want to be with her
okay and um that went
all the way up for about a year we had
the divorce papers filed we were just
about divorced and then
he was getting into graduate school out
here in tennessee
and we were getting ready to move and
right before it was like two weeks
before we moved he was like
no i really do want to try in our
relationship i've cut things off with
her
i'm completely committed to our marriage
and
then we started our marriage out here
okay so take me back to that one moment
why did you choose to stay with him um
i had chosen to stay with him the whole
time just
partly because i knew that if he would
come back to how he used to be that we
would be really good together
we had always been really good together
we'd always been really good
friends and i mean he had
before all that he had been you know the
love of my life and everything that i
had wanted and
he's such a good dad and and partner
and i knew that we could get that back
if he
committed back to the relationship and i
didn't want to let that go
so he
he has recommitted am i right
yes but it's not the way things were is
that right
well that's the thing is he our
relationship is
better now than it was before before all
of that happened
even at the beginning of our marriage in
a lot of ways our
marriage is a lot better than it ever
was okay um
he really when he committed he 100
committed and he i mean i went through a
lot of therapy to kind of help myself
heal
and work through things and he
i mean just put a lot of effort into our
relationship and
so what do you mean here what's the dot
dot dot i feel i feel
a shoe about to drop well there's no
big shoe it's just before all of that
happened you know he was like i said
the love of my life and even though
things are so much better now
i'm not as in love with him as i was
before
and where he says like i'm the most in
love i've ever been in our relationship
and he's the happiest he's ever been in
our relationship
i'm not there yet because i still feel
like there's this
black mark there and the person that i
thought he was he
wasn't really because he was able to do
all of these extremely hurtful
things gotcha and so
you've you were hurt so
here's one of the analogies i use we all
carry backpacks around
right and
let's assume and usually this isn't
fully accurate but let's just assume
here
that you had you played no role in
the affair things were perfect
you were the dream partner he was the
dream partner
and he just had a girlfriend for a year
and a half they just couldn't give up
fully and if you think in those terms of
the backpack he picked up a cinder block
and just
dropped it in your backpack right he
wrecked what you thought was perfect and
you've been through therapy you have
recommitted yourself to one another
you've forgiven him and for some reason
you're still carrying this around with
you
tell me why you will not put that brick
down
because it's not weighing him down do
you have little kids too
yeah we have three little ones okay so
you got three little ones how old are
they
i have a seven-year-old a four-year-old
and a one-year-old
oh my gosh okay
on top of a pandemic too right because
why not
right in graduate school and why not
all right so why are you still holding
this brick
why are you still carrying it i feel
like some days
i've let it go you haven't some days
you may take the whole backpack off but
for some reason you're still carrying it
why
i think part of me is afraid it'll
happen again can i tell you something
that sucks
it might yeah all relationships are risk
right and there's a part of your heart
and mind that was completely gutted when
this happened last time
and there's a part in your heart and
mind that is constantly vigilant for it
might happen again
right and that is a tiny little sliver a
tiny little fracture in your
relationship
that will be there until you fully
decide to put this brick down
and that means you're going to fully
risk getting hurt again
and it might happen again i hope it
never does but it might
but one thing you're you are for sure
making sure happens
is that you never fully give it a full
go because you're still hanging on to
that thing
and the only way to truly lean into this
deal
is if you put that brick down did it
hurt
yes was it your fault nope did it happen
yeah here's the other thing
or leave
right and it took me a long time to to
accept the fact that i wasn't stuck in
this relationship by the time we decided
to stay together
and that i was choosing to stay right
for the first year
we were recovering i was resentful and
feel like i was
tricked and and stuck in this situation
and
but i have moved past that but every
once in a while that
thought comes back so i want to back out
real quick
and give you this piece just as an
outsider okay
you have a seven a four and a one year
old you're in graduate school in the
middle of a pandemic
in a relatively new state
i want you to give yourself some grace
here okay
if you had the single greatest husband
who'd ever lived who was perfect and
only had eyes for you
forever things would still feel
wonky and out of place right now
things would still feel like a dumpster
fire because they are
okay and you put this on top of that
here's the thing if you said i forgive
you
there comes a moment and hear me
carefully okay
if you said i forgive you and i'm a
hundred percent in
have you all had another child y'all had
another baby since this huh
we did yes okay so you've you are so in
we made another human together
if you continue to carry this backpack
around
you are choosing to injure the people in
your home with it
does that make sense it does
how do i because like i said there's a
lot
and more and more there are days that i
don't have it
and it tends to be the days that i am
dealing with depression a little bit
more or maybe my anxiety pops up that
these thoughts come up more perfectly
they don't really know how to
get it out at that point so have you
have you heard of me talk about
david kessler's work and the purple
elephant
uh is that just the the uh focusing your
mind
controlling your thoughts i guess there
you go so close your eyes real quick
you got it and i want you to imagine all
three of your kids standing on top of
one another
outside in the front yard you're
one-year-old on the top of that little
kid pyramid
you got it and you see your
one-year-old up there with like a yellow
hat on
and they're just waving in the wind and
you're afraid they're going to fall do
you see them
yes okay open your eyes you just proved
to millions of people that you can
control your thoughts
you can't control what pops in there but
you can control what you choose to focus
on
and so the commitment you have to decide
is am i all in
if you are all in what you're going to
do over the next few months
over the next few years as you continue
to heal
is you're going gonna have to recognize
you're gonna have to come to terms with
he could do this again
he probably won't let's hope let's give
him the benefit of the doubt my hope is
that you love him and know him enough
that
you would not have agreed to continue on
if if you really thought that was going
to happen
and then every time she pops into your
mind
you get to decide from that point
forward am i going to meditate on this
am i going to let it
set off all my alarms or am i going to
intentionally think of
a wonderful thing my husband's done
if every time that you wake up and
you're feeling anxious and you haven't
slept because you got a one-year-old and
you're exhausted and you're just eating
twinkies because they're so good
and your nutrition's low and then you
just
all of a sudden are struck with that day
that he told you
hey we gotta talk and your stomach drops
and you get that warm feeling in your
stomach
that's the moment you get to decide nope
and in my house i actually say it out
loud
nope it's kind of become a joke with my
wife and my son my daughter doesn't
recognize it yet but i'll just be like
nope
and that's just me announcing i'm not
gonna think about that
and now i've been doing it long enough
that literally it will go away
if an old crisis scene pops in my head
an old thing that i said to my wife an
old thing i did
um you know in the past pops into my
head i will go
nope and i will replace it with another
thought that's positive
because i get to make that choice and
you've got to be
graceful with yourself because it's hard
and it takes time
right that grace for yourself is
it's a slow process
how much of this affair do you blame
yourself for
um i think at the beginning it was a lot
okay because during the time that it
happened i was
physically sick i was dealing with
postpartum depression from my
second and i was you know we were both
working full-time
jobs on opposite schedules and so i felt
like i wasn't
a good enough wife and partner and
blamed myself quite a bit
and and like i said
i did a lot a lot of therapy i was in
therapy like two or three times a week
sure for almost a year here's the part
the kind of work done here's the part
that therapists often don't tell you
about okay
you have the initial shock that
devastating shock
of the affair but what they don't tell
you about is
you lose trust in yourself
yeah and you lose trust in how did i let
this happen how did i not see this why
am i still with this guy what is wrong
with me
why am i having another kid with they
don't tell you that you lose trust in
yourself
and the person i want you to get
re-acquainted with
is you charlie because you are worth
treating yourself right
and the more you feel at home in your
own body
is the more you feel at home with this
guy
the more your brain will go all right
we're safe and by the way you just gave
me
a hint here was this about the age your
your second child was when you found out
he was yeah so he was about 15 months
when i found out yeah so you're right
smack in the middle of it your brain is
saying
we remember this we remember this watch
out
right i didn't really think about that
oh my gosh i should have a podcast
i'm a genius you see that kelly genius
um not really charlie not really charlie
but um
yeah so i want to number one thank you
so much
for the call be kind to yourself love
yourself
let your brain off the hook
and recognize that all relationship
starts with risk
people hurt one another they forgive one
another but if you've forgiven him
and you're choosing to continue to
weaponize this
then suddenly you're going to find
yourself becoming the offender in the
house
and that gap in that relationship is
going to affect your kids it's going to
affect your marriage
and so if you're all in be all in and
that means
risking pain sometime down down the way
and you're worth it tell your alarms
you're all right
tell them thank you for looking out for
you but tell me all right